I'd like to talk about grace because why
not I've always loved the sound of that
word grace when I think of grace I think
gratitude I think of bliss and I think
of faith all at once like those three
qualities had a baby that baby would be
grace grace is what you feel on the
other side of the rainbow grace is what
you feel through the looking-glass when
you commit to an act of kindness when
you perform an act of kindness in the
world you get a taste of grace grace
feels like we've turned our passing
illuminations into abiding light grace
is that scene in V for Vendetta
where Natalie Portman says God is in the
rain grace is transformation
grace is metamorphosis you know they say
that our cells are a technology that
turns experience into biology right you
become tattooed transformed by your
actions in the world and grace is what
happens when those actions have brought
you nourishment and brought you
gratitude have brought you
so that's grace
[Music]
you